wait do you hear the sound
today might be a very big day something
we've been waiting for for
two months for the municipality to clean
the roads and it sounds like they're
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so let me quickly explain what's going
on here so we have two shipping
containers that need to go here with all
our stuff
but in order to go to the land you need
to go over a road but the road was
completely overgrown and bushy and you
couldn't access it with a big truck
now it's part of the municipality the
responsibility to keep the
public to keep the public roads clean
and this was a public road so they had
to do it so the moment we arrived
basically we knew this needed to happen
and we got attached to municipality they
said we'll clean it next week
next week nothing happened we called
them again they dropped by at the land
they looked at the road they said i will
do it next week
next week nothing happened so we kept
calling went to the municipality office
to really
formally post them with a letter
the president even came to check was all
good next week they'll do it
next week nothing happened so we kind of
gave up a little bit the hope i would
say after what two and a half months
so i was just at the edge of started to
do it myself
so this is not really true i actually
did start myself
making these spots more white so the
truck can enter
chopping down this and this so i
borrowed the chainsaw
is not a very complex job or anything
just chopping trees and bushes
so as you can see on the map we are here
and the main road is here so base camp
is set up here and the start of the dirt
road here
so we need to clean up this 1.8
kilometers of road
and besides chopping the bushes it also
means fixing the holes in the road
it's it's just a lot so i got a bit
demotivated to continue
and now today these guys show up i mean
super nice actually that they finally
managed to do it feels
like a bit of a relief
so thinking maybe you guys should all
support on patreon so you can buy a
machine like that
i mean that would make everything a bit
faster
so this is now all cleaned up on the
roads
and then they take it away and we have a
clean big route
so
[Music]
making a stream so the water can flow up
the land
so that took a day to make flat
then this guy shows up
[Music]
he's also struggling
[Applause]
[Music]
there was so much work to make
so originally i made this nice patio
here where we can put the container and
had some bushes around for a shadow
but now the truck came and just cleared
all the
trees out so yeah we
might rethink where this thing is going
to be
this is what the big machines do
roads are now cleaned and the bushes are
thrown on the side and the roads are now
ready
for a container to come time to do
something fun
and this week we realized the highest
mountain of portugal is actually very
close by
so we are here and the mountain is here
with apparently snow
so we have to check that
in
out
it feels like being not in portugal some
futuristic abandoned structures
with some normal abandoned structures
with a funny build wall looks like a
cardboard decorative building or
something
and some very sharp gravity life it what
happened to you
while you're busy make another plane
and there's actually quite a lot of snow
around here
and also there we have the only ski
slope
outdoor of portugal if you go
wintersport
in portugal
thank you
but very fresh chilly air and a
beautiful view
and i didn't really expect to find this
scenario around here
super cool so after inhaling some fresh
air and making some yellow snow we drove
home with a snowball as a souvenir
alright so we're back home again
unfortunately the snowball did
not make it all the way here
yeah but it was still a good week
because remember the previous video
where i shared our three biggest
challenges
get electricity get an address
and clean the roads so we can swipe off
that one
which is actually seems like a small
thing but it was kind of a big one here
took a few months
so next step is that the containers can
actually use the road and come here
which is very exciting and a big upgrade
for the base camp
so yeah if you want to see those future
updates make sure to subscribe
if you want to see all our previous
updates make sure to go here
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcomp.com to see how
you can help out
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video